A "time capsule" is a container used to store for posterity a selection of objects...
...thought to be representative of life at a particular time.
Time capsules are interesting to people of all ages...
...and touch people on a worldwide scale.
Properly prepared time capsules...
...preserve the unique and relevant features of history...
...and can serve as valuable reminders of one generation for another.
Time capsules give individuals,...
...families and organizations an independent voice to the future.
Time Capsule Making Tips.
One. Select a retrieval date. Centennial (100 - year) time capsules are popular.
Two. Choose an "archivist" and make committees to share the work load.
Three. Select a container.
Safes are excellent because they're cool, dry, and dark.
Four. Find a secure indoor location. Don't bury it!
Mark the location with a plaque describing the time capsule's "mission".
Five. Select items that will have meaning into the future...
...from the sublime to the trivial.
Don't forget to make an inventory.
Six. Have a solemn "sealing ceremony"...
...and formally christen the time capsule with a name.
Invite the media and make a good photographic record...
...including the inside of your time capsule.
Seven. Don't forget your time capsule!
Renew the tradition of memory with anniversaries and reunions.
Send out invitations to the projected opening. Be creative.
Eight. Inform the International Time Capsule Society.
The ITCS will add your time capsule to its database...
...in an attempt to register all known time capsules.